hey everyone it's my photos welcome to
the early morning edition of the order
flows market analysis for Tuesday
October 17 2017 it is for 11:00 a.m.
Chicago time and I thought I'd get this
little video sort of get myself back
into making these videos every day last
week I don't think I really made that
many videos but see we're taking a break
I got some stuff going on in my life I
needed to address and I also got this
webinar coming out on Thursday the 19th
so if you haven't registered be sure to
register for it I'll be talking about
some things I haven't really covered in
previous webinars so you should be
interesting so let's just get started a
brief disclaimer as required by law this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation a buy or
sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision future
strain contagious natural risk and it's
not for every investor investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that could be lost without jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results you know
some people ask me why why do you bother
with this disclaimer in every video well
one you know the CFTC requires it you
know when you talk about the markets it
can be construed as financial advice you
know I remember when I when I moved to
Singapore and I had to take this they
they out they have you know in the u.s.
you have the series three and that's it
it's quite basic but in Singapore you
really got to be taken like a financial
advisors program or licensed to in order
to trade they've actually added an
additional license you have to to take
in order to be you know like working in
the bank you have to have these these
different modules with the Monetary
Authority of Singapore because basically
you know if somebody calls the bank and
it says hey bothos what's your view on
the Japanese yen you know and I say I I
think you should buy you know that can
be construed as advice and you know it's
just one of those things that you know
it's you know people come to trading
because
you think they they see these videos
they see people posting themselves with
next to Ferrari's on Instagram and stuff
and majority of all that stuff is just
get rich quick hype and you know people
do get rich trading be the first to
admit that and but you know people also
get rich selling houses okay that
doesn't mean that you know they go out
and they flip a house tomorrow and make
a million dollars in their instant
millionaire no it takes time right it
takes work you know you work your way up
to to success in the markets and just as
you would in any other industry so you
need to learn what's what's required to
become successful in the markets in
other words don't quit your day job yet
you know unless you can devote yourself
to trading in the markets and you know
go all-in so to speak you know give it
your full concentration and you know
your full attention then you know don't
quit your day job yet unless unless
you're willing to commit yourself to the
markets so the tools I use in this
presentation are the order flow trader
the Delta scalper the price rejector and
you know the order flows trader is the
volume footprint chart Delta scalper is
the tool I use to help read the Delta in
the markets and the price rejector is
the tool I use to show signs of price
rejection in the order flow you know
these two indicators are additional
indicators that help traders analyze the
order flow without having and do it
themselves you know I understand that
you know there's a lot to look at in an
order flow right and coming in as a
beginning trader to order flow you may
not know what's going on and you know
this is similar to trading with you know
having looking at so many markets and
having so many positions on at once you
can't keep track of what the heck is
going on and with order flow well you
know you got a lot of things to look at
and sometimes it's it's hard to keep
your focus that's why I create a couple
tools to help sort of narrow it down and
take that analysis off from you because
you know when you come in to order flow
anything oh my gosh I gotta be looking
at Delta oh my gosh I gotta be looking
at imbalances oh my gosh I gotta be
looking at this type of Prince things
like that it can't become very
overwhelming you know I found the people
that do well with order flow are the
ones that stick
to a few things and you know build their
trading plan and their method of trading
around those things whether it's the
Delta scalper nor Delta by itself or
imbalances by itself you know they get
the understanding and then they build on
that from there so that's why you know I
create these tools is to sort of give
you that building block because you know
I see other people you know there's just
another a new order flow software just
came out another another footprint chart
you know three years ago they were only
about half a dozen footprint charts out
there now there's twice as many out
there but you know what's the point of
putting out a footprint chart you know
for traders if you're not going to teach
them what to look for and you know how
to trade with the with the footprint you
know I mean it is just you know it's
just a tool okay sorry I just got
interrupted there but anyway let's just
jump in and start looking at some charts
enough of this preaching here okay so
this morning I got an email from
somebody relatively new to the order
flows trader software and he was asking
me if there was in the euro currency if
there was the o2x trade actually I don't
see one this morning I mean I'm gonna go
back to I got a reply to his email but
what I saw though in this morning was
off this low here I don't see any reason
we bind this too low here with the
divergence or this low with the
divergence but this low here with the
divergence I guess they got three failed
divergences that watch out if we take
out this low here one 1792 and 1/2 if we
take out that low later in the day
advisee look to this to sell it but what
you have in this low is the divergence
and you got the ratio afterwards to me
that's very bullish you also have the
Delta scalper on that low as well so I
know that something's happening in the
Delta and it is changing on me pretty
quick and you know be alert so you know
you got the Delta scalper and you got
the ratio and divergence in the next bar
even if you get in a bit late up here at
the Oh 100 - level you did get a nice
move all the way up here - you know
above 10
you got another bearish ratio here
another barrel it's a bearish ratio then
you got the Delta scalper gave a sell
and it just chopped on you back and
forth before selling back down here or
we now we're coming back down to the low
here so I'll be very curious to see how
it's gonna if it's gonna take out this
low or not
pretty soon again you know 92 and a half
is that low if we take it out I wouldn't
be surprised I said you got failed
divergence fail divergence divergence
that did hold we did rally up a bit but
again we're testing that low again I
wouldn't be surprised for coming into it
with a bearish ratio and a bearish ratio
I wouldn't be surprised to see us break
through that low we'll see thing that
could happen pretty soon actually okay
so this is the yen it kind of a quiet
morning today in the in the in the yen
we do have this low that was made here
about two o'clock just after 2:00 and
you got a divergence you got the ratio
in the next party to go up I mean this
kind of went sideways here did test the
high again which was encouraging sort of
came off but right now we're just
hanging around unchanged right now so
really nothing to get too excited about
I mean if you're a long in this trade
you know I I wouldn't still be hanging
around in there you know it's 2 o'clock
until 4:30 and it's just as sort of just
going nowhere honestly after after it's
after it fails to take out this high
here sort of comes back down I'd be just
looking to get out what you can out of
the trade rather than you know wait for
it if we're gonna take out the high or
anything now just get outs in our didn't
pay off get out of it okay the Aussie
dollar this morning again also kind of
similar to the end kind of kind of tight
range at this low here 158 you do have
the price rejector that's this green
line here it's a doji bar you know but
it is showing some signs price rejection
at low to me which is important we
rallied up to this to the high today
actually made a new high you got a
divergence no ratio and we're chill just
hang it around here now that's
interesting because look at this bar
that we're in right now in the Aussie
weirded a trade back up to treated right
up to that point of control of the bar
on the high which again you know if
you're looking for the market
come off watch you know the bar that's
the high they look at the point control
watch that level you know if if we
really don't start to sell off this
level should hold right we should rally
back up to that level or around that
level and then sell off which right now
it is but again it is this very
slow-moving market we've been in this
bar for 45 minutes and there's just not
a lot going on in these Asian currencies
at the moment okay there's a British
Pound really quick so you know from two
to three we started making these new
highs here no reason to be selling in
these highs you get this one you know a
possible sell you know you got the the
negative Delta you got the red candle
but yeah you know if I want a little bit
more here you got a you know you got
this small imbalance here for you got a
single print which indicates price
rejection you've got a divergence so you
got you're starting to see some signs in
there and but but look like what I was
just trying to explain to you in the in
the Aussie don't excuse me
in the Aussie dollar okay so you know
here you have your high all right you
got the red candle this next bar in
order to trade it up there than the
candle ended and you went higher now
you've got a new high you got a red
candle point of control right here where
did this bar trade - traded right up to
that point of control got one tick
through it okay fair enough one tick
through it's not like traded all the way
up back up here it's holding so that's a
sign that you know this high might hold
you're seeing the resistance levels
being put in with the point of control
and this one sells off relatively nicely
I mean obviously we had a number come
out of this 330 here and that's why you
see some sort of thin volume there you
get back up here you test you get within
a few points a few ticks at a high you
got the red arrow indicating an
imbalance up there on the high some
trapped traders it says this is a trap
trader signal you know you had it up
here you have it here you know in both
times the market sold off here you have
a stacked imbalance that failed and
we're just a little bit lower right now
I'll say a little bit lower we round
unchanged I mean we're lower from the
high is what I mean speaking of which
let me take a look
back at that mural courtesy see what
that's doing okay so the operation was a
success the operation was a success
success but the patient died we did make
a new low like I said I was expecting us
to make a new low
we made a low by a tick and then we
bounced back up here we took out the low
of 92 and a half went down to 92 and we
are back up 99 right now but again you
got another divergence we'll see if this
one's gonna hold as well again this is
the thing that I hate about breakout
trading breakouts is this you know I
used to be a big breakout trader back in
the 90s and that was my that was my
whole thing as my whole spiel was
arrange extension breakouts from Tom to
mark and and Larry Williams and you know
technically that's a breakout but it's a
break up by one tick but you know then
you get a bounce so you get in short
here and what happens is next thing you
know it's it's it's rallied against you
you get stopped out that's the problem
you face with breakouts not all
breakouts work you know here right if
you traded this first breakout yeah that
was nice you got from you know Ford
almost straight down to 94 but then if
you're selling this breakout you get
this bounce back up here you're not
gonna take that much heat you're gonna
get stopped out and hopefully look for
another breakout but anyway I don't I
won't get into that whole trading
strategy I gotta find my old my notes
with it you know it's it's it's it's one
of those things right there's that
saying in sports quitters never win and
winners never quit well you know it's
even though you know this whole deranged
extension breakouts is is a profitable
way to trade you know the whole Toby
cradle funds you know it's how many
billions of dollars is was built around
range extension breakouts this doesn't
mean that you know what he's doing now
is what he was doing you know back in
the 90s you know his trading evolved so
it's not like you quit necessarily I
don't say I quit arrange extension
breakout trading I've moved on to other
forms of trading you know even though I
don't trade that way right now I guess
you know it's not like why I quit that
way no you know sometimes in the back of
my head I'm always looking at when we're
coming into highs or lows yeah
I still want to know are we gonna hold
or are we gonna break out of those or
what's gonna happen so you know it's
it's not necessarily that quote that's
truly applicable to trading I mean I can
understand yeah
if you quit trading you'll never win a
trading yeah but I mean just because you
know you you move away from a method of
trading doesn't necessarily mean you
know you quit it you just moved on to
something else that you feel works a
little bit better and you know I mean
it's a game of inches in trading you
know it's you know this works a little
bit better so I'll stick with that and
on and they don't want to say this I
mean you know the new your your new
method of trading you know you're always
trying to improve your trading in one
way or another so you know if you can
incrementally unfortunately that's how
it generally works in trading you're
incrementally in improving your trading
it's not by big giant steps as usually
it's I said I'll say it's a process but
it's work right it's it's something that
happens over time you get better and
better and better at it so sometimes you
move away from one method of trading and
into another another method of trading
so anyway that will conclude it for
today and again you know if you haven't
registered for my webinar please do you
know it's I try to keep these things
informative yeah I know there's a little
bit of a spiel on the end but you know I
pushed my software but again you know
the reasons why I pushed my software's
because I feel it's good I feel it adds
value for the trader you know I mean at
the end of the day that's what you want
to do you people just want to learn how
to trade and sometimes it doesn't cost
money to learn yeah it does and you
could sit around in the dark you could
go out and buy you know an order flow
charting software a volume footprint
chart for a couple hundred bucks not
even maybe in less than 100 bucks at
some places but if you're not going to
get the resources or the training or the
guides or anything like that what's the
point you know I mean what's what's the
point it's it just doesn't make sense I
mean just wasting your money because
then you'll never really learn how to
how to trade with order flow I mean you
can I mean you could
wander around in the desert and sooner
or later the Sun will come up but it
could be a long time before the Sun
comes up so anyway thanks for watching
this and thanks for listening to me
preach have a great day and bye bye
everyone